KAMALA BREAK DOWN.
BUT FIRST, THE REAL BITTER
CLEANERS, THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT ANGLE.
I REMEMBER WHEN OBAMA DESCRIBED
US CONSERVATIVES AS BITTER
PEOPLE CLINGING TO OUR GUNS AND
OUR RELIGION?
WELL, NOW WE SEE WHO THE REAL
BITTER CLEANERS REALLY ARE.
SCHIFF, SCHUMER, NADLER, PELOSI,
ROMNEY, BOLTON, JUST TO NAME A
FEW.
ALL OF THEM IN THEIR OWN WAYS
ARE VERY ANGRY PEOPLE.
THEY CLING FLEXIBLY TO AN
IDEOLOGY THAT MOST PEOPLE DON’T
RELATE TO ANYMORE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY RAPID AND RADICAL.
THEY ARE TURNING OFF MOST SANE
PEOPLE.
BOLTON IS A POSTER CHILD FOR THE
NEOCON NEVER TRUMP CROWD, STILL
FANTASIZING OF THE GLORY DAYS OF
DEPLOYING 100,000 TROOPS FOR
NATION-BUILDING IN IRAQ.
THE LEFT AND RIGHT HAVE REJECTED
HIS WORLDVIEW YET SOMEHOW HE
LANDED THE NFC JOB IN THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE.
FORTUNATE FOR US,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS TOO SMART TO
FALL FOR ALL THAT NONSENSE.
A BLANK CHECK FOR ANY COUNTRY
CLAIMING TO BE AN ALLEY WITH
THEIR HAND STRETCHED OUT?
NOT THE TRUMP DOCTRINE, BABY.
AS FOR CAN I GET A WITNESS
ROMNEY?
HE’S BETTER TOO.
HE CAN’T BELIEVE SOMEONE OF HIS
PEDIGREE AND UPBRINGING EVER
LOST A PRESIDENCY.
THEN A MAN LIKE TRUMP WON IT.
2012 IS OVER, MITT.
DON’T PUNISH TRUMP OR THE REST
OF US FOR YOUR OWN WEAKNESS AS A
CANDIDATE.
LAST NIGHT I TITLED THE ANGLE
"24 HOURS TO VICTORY."
THAT IS CORRECT BECAUSE TODAY
TRUMP TRIUMPHED OVER THE UNFAIR,
UNJUST AND POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
WITCH HUNT.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS CANNOT ACCEPT
DEFEAT.
AS WE TOLD YOU TIME AND TIME
AGAIN, WHEN THEY LOSE, THEY CALL
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED BEFORE
ILLEGITIMATE.
BUT NOW EVEN THE LIBERAL MEDIA,
THEY ARE HAVING A HARD TIME
SPENDING IT.
SPEAK UP TRUMP WON.
HE’S GOING TO WIN THIS TRIAL.
HE WON ON THE ISSUE OF
WITNESSES, HE’S GOING TO GET
ACQUITTED.
THAT IS HOW HISTORY WILL
REMEMBER WHAT WENT ON HERE.
>> Laura: IT’S OVER, THEY
LOST, TRUMP WON.
TWO OF THEM HAVE TO ADMIT IT SO
LET’S MOVE ON.
NO, THAT WOULD BE THE GRACIOUS
THING TO DO.
INSTEAD THE DEMOCRATS ARE
DRAGGING IT OUT IN A PATHETIC
ATTEMPT ON TRUMP’S STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS AND GRATUITOUSLY
RUIN THE SUPER BOWL FOR THE REST
OF US.
THE IOWA CAUCUSES, WHO CARES
ABOUT THOSE NOW?
THEY ARE DEEPLY BETTER, SELFLESS
AND SELF-AGGRANDIZING PEOPLE.
THEY ARE BITTER ONCE AGAIN
BECAUSE TRUMP HAS BEATEN THEM AT
THEIR OWN GAME AND ONCE AGAIN,
MITCH McCONNELL, THAT SLY,
WILY OLD DOG IN THE SENATE
OUTMANEUVERED ALL OF THEM.
AND ONCE AGAIN, SOME OF THE
RADICALS AND THEIR PARTY ARE
JUST REPELLING THE PUBLIC IN THE
SUPPORT OF KEY SENATORS THEY
NEEDED.
SENATOR MURKOWSKI WAS SO TURNED
OFF BY ELIZABETH WARREN’S
STUNNED, DEMEANING THE CHIEF
JUSTICE WITH A QUESTION LAST
NIGHT THAT SHE REJECTED
WITNESSES BECAUSE OF IT.
SHE WROTE, I WILL NOT STAND FOR
NOR SUPPORT THAT EFFORT.
WHILE CHUCK AND ADAM TILT AT
WINDMILLS, PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHAT
HAS HE DONE?
HE HAS CHOPPED UP SOME FANTASTIC
VICTORIES THIS WEEK.
THE USMCA AND A BOWL OF
MIDDLE EAST PEACE PLAN TO NAME A
COUPLE.
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION IS
MANAGING A GLOBAL CONTAGION THAT
IS THREATENING LIVES AND THE
INTERNATIONAL MARKET.
HE ALSO SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER TO DISMANTLE SOME OF THE
WORLD’S WORST CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISES.
SPEAK OF MY ADMINISTRATION IS
FIGHTING THESE MONSTERS,
PERSECUTING AND PROSECUTING THEM
AND LOCKING THEM AWAY FOR A
VERY, VERY LONG TIME.
WE ARE DISMANTLING THE CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MAKE
LARGE-SCALE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
POSSIBLE.
>> Laura: BUT THE POLITICAL
GAINS ARE NOT OVER, NOT BY A
LONG SHOT.
I WARNED YOU THE OTHER NIGHT
THAT THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA
WOULD DROP ONE SHINY OBJECT
AFTER ANOTHER AND DO IT IN FRONT
OF US AS AN ATTEMPT TO KIND OF
DRAG THIS OUT AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE.
THEY’RE WAITING IN THE WAITING
PERIOD AND RIGHT ON CUE, OF
COURSE "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
CONVENIENTLY DROPPED ANOTHER
LIMIT OUR EXCLUSIVE, FED BY
SOURCES WHO CLAIM TO HAVE READ
JOHN BOLTON’S UNPUBLISHED
MANUSCRIPT.
SPEAK OUT THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THIS CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED.
BOLTON SEEMS TO HAVE LICK IT ALL
PLAYERS.
>> SUDDENLY THERE IS NO
INFORMATION INVOLVING
PAT CIPOLLONE ACTUALLY BEING IN
A ROOM WHERE SOME OF THIS
HAPPENED.
>> IT ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTS ME.
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY THE END OF
"CLUE."
THE BUTLER DID IT IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
>> Laura: NOW IT IS OBVIOUS TO
ANYONE WITH A PULSE THAT THIS IS
NOTHING MORE THAN A CALCULATED,
ANONYMOUSLY SOURCED HIT JOB.
A LAST-DITCH ATTEMPT TO SWAY
SITTING SENATORS.
BUT ADAM SCHIFF WANTS YOU TO
BELIEVE IT IS GOSPEL.
>> YOU WILL RECALL
MR. PAT CIPOLLONE SUGGESTING THE
HOUSE MANAGERS WERE CONCEALING
FACTS FROM THIS BODY.
YOU SET ALL THE FACTS COULD COME
OUT.
WELL, THERE IS A NEW FACT WHICH
INDICATES THAT MR. CIPOLLONE WAS
AMONG THOSE IN THE LOOP HERE
JUST AS WE PREDICTED, AND IT
DIDN’T REQUIRE ANY ACT OF
CLAIRVOYANCE, THE FACTS WILL
COME OUT.
>> Laura: NEVER MIND THAT THE
ALREADY ISSUED A BLANKET
STATEMENT SAYING THE MEDIA NEVER
HAPPENED.
SO SCHIFF WILL DO ANYTHING TO
KEEP THIS HUSTLE ALIVE.
WHAT ELSE DOES HE HAVE?
EVEN IF IT MEANS TARNISHING THE
REPUTATIONS OF GOOD MEN LIKE
PAT CIPOLLONE.
SCHIFF KNOWS HE IS LOST AND HE
KNOWS THAT HE AND ALL THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GRASPING AT ANY
CLAIM NO MATTER HOW TENUOUS THE
STRING TO FAKE IMPEACHMENT AND
KEEP IT GOING, KEEP IT GOING,
KEEP GOING.
CHUCK SCHUMER IS ALREADY
REFUSING TO ACCEPT THE RESULTS
OF THE NEXT ELECTION UNLESS OF
COURSE SOMETHING HAPPENS BETWEEN
NOW AND WEDNESDAY AND TRUMP HAS
JUST REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
>> IF THIS PRESIDENT IS
INTERFERING IN THE ELECTION,
ELECTIONS MAY NOT HAVE A FAIR
RESULT.
VERY FEW PEOPLE DOUBT THAT HE
WOULD DO IT AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
HE HAS ALREADY TRIED SEVERAL
TIMES.
>> Laura: HE’S DONE IT SEVERAL
TIMES CUSTOMER THIS IS FROM A
MAN WHO SUPPORTS STRIKING
TRUMP’S NAME FROM THE BALLOT IN
NOVEMBER WHILE FORCING MAJOR
CANDIDATES IN HIS OWN
PARTY OFF THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
JUST DAYS BEFORE THE IOWA
CAUCUSES.
AND TRUMP IS THE ONE INTERFERING
IN ELECTIONS?
NO, IT’S YOU AND SCHIFF AND THE
ENTIRE DEMOCRAT GANG FOR PUTTING
THEIR FINGERS ON THE SCALE FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC ESTABLISHMENT.